bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur lcp
public sénat c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de l'info politique et
parlementaire avec michaël szames est
notre invité cette semaine c'est eric
ciotti bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
les républicains des alpes-maritimes
porte parole de nicolas sarkozy pour
cette campagne des primaires à droite
troisième débat qui a eu lieu ce jeudi
soir dernier débat de la primaire à
droite
pas de vainqueur net maintient ses deux
têtes qui se dégage alain juppé nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon
verdict des sympathisants ce dimanche et
puis reviendra sur ce double coup de
théâtre à l'assemblée le gouvernement a
été mis en échec sur le prélèvement à la
source mesure phare du budget 2010 est
la droite plus mobilisés que les
socialistes a réussi à bloquer
momentanément l'adoption de la réforme
et au sénat le budget ne sera pas
examinée en entier la majorité
sénatoriale dénonce un budget insincère
et puis on reviendra sur la polémique
provoquée par le média fichier ce qu'on
appelle le tess il contient du données
personnelles de millions de français
madame 15 9
il est venu justifier sa mise en place
devant le parlement les sénateurs
demandent sa suspension mais l'actualité
politique d'abord avec un retour sur
l'ultime débat pour la primaire à droite
dernier débat donc ce jeudi pas d'
attaques frontales mais quelques piques
quand même notamment celle de jean
françois copé qui accuse françois
failliot dette en quelque sorte le co
responsable de l'échec du quinquennat
écouter est-ce que lorsque j'entends
tout ce programme de rupture qui vient
s'inscrire aujourd'hui est ce que ça
signifie que il aurait adoré réformer
dans le quinquennat précédent mexique
nicolas sarkozy qu'il en a empêchés
personne ne peut le penser
je viens de me faire traiter d'un poster
dans un débat qui jusqu'à maintenant
avait une certaine tenue à droite voilà
en quelque sorte ce débat avec ce titre
d'un petit peu haro sur françois fillon
c'est nouveau il vous fait peur vous
françois fillon non je crois qu'on n'est
pas à l'égard de quelques candidats que
ce soit dans ce sentiment d'abord on est
dans la même famille politique je crois
que le débat a été une compétition va
sans doute mise à part ces attaques de
jean françois copé qu'il a sans doute
oublié qu'il a présidé pendant plusieurs
années le groupe parlementaire
majoritaire en revendiquant la
coproduction législative je n'ai pas
souvenir de l'avoir entendu en premier
opposant de ce que faisait le
gouvernement à l'époque mais c'est sans
doute un problème de mémoire de jean
françois copé je vous parle de françois
fillon parce que là on le voit bien et
remonte dans les sondages françois copé
vous venez de l'absolu mans qui a porté
cette attaque qui dénotait dans le débat
le débat a été de bonne tenue de qualité
comme les autres des ballons et aux
responsables du bilan ou pas françois
fillon françois fillon nicolas sarkozy
alain juppé bruno le maire ont été
ministre et jean-françois copé je le
redis présidente du groupe majoritaire
nous sommes tous moi en tant que députés
sont personnellement j'assume je
revendique même ce bilan ce bilan de
nicolas sarkozy puisque c'était lui le
chef de l'état c'est un bilan qui a
permis à la france de tenir choc pendant
la crise c'est un bilan qui a permis de
ne jamais reculer devant la rue
même lorsqu'il ya eu la réforme des
retraites lorsqu'il ya eu la réforme
mais françois fillon était le premier
ministre qui a mis en place la politique
voulue par les français en votant pour
nicolas sarkozy l'a dit d'ailleurs hier
soir très clairement non bien sûr qu'il
est solidaire de il ya quelques temps on
vous parle de françois fillon parce
qu'il ya quelques temps pas si éloigné
que ça vous étiez parmi les soutiens
françois fillon aujourd'hui vous assumez
votre choix d'être un soutien à nicolas
sarkozy quand vous voyez la surprise que
peut créer finalement françois fillon
j'ai soutenu françois fillon dans le
cadre de l'élection à la présidence de
l'ump est naturellement non seulement je
leur donnerais pas mais si c'était à
refaire je le ferai c'était un débat
face à jean françois copé
je soutiens nicolas sarkozy dans cette
primaire d'abord par fidélité je suis
avec lui depuis 1988 à des titres
différents
et parce que je considère en conscience
qu'il a le meilleur projet pour la
france et surtout qu'il a l'expérience
et l'énergie pour le transformer en
actes
on va rentrer dans une période nous
sommes dans une période
extraordinairement difficile ce sera
peut-être encore plus difficile de même
pour réparer les dégâts des socialistes
pour faire face aux communautarismes
terrorisme à la faillite
il faudra de l'expérience il faudra d un
projet fort un projet de rupture c'est
nicolas sarkzoy tour où vous il n'y a
pas de doute sur l'issue de ce premier
tour gestion de ferrari chez colas
sarkozy sera en tête dimanche soir jean
souhaite profondément convaincu on sent
sur le terrain l'adhésion le souffle les
français qui le soutiennent
parce qu'il porte il voit l'énergie
qu'il incarne donc je n'ai aucun doute
là dessus de votre duo gagnant à qui
alain juppé ou françois fillon a sonné
désormais dans ce match vous avez raison
de le poser on verra bien une
incertitude qui était forte
en tout cas pour vous c'est certain
nicolas sarkozy vous fait ce pari il
sera un pas en tête c'est simple il
important parce que j'avais des
retraites le premier tour car dimanche
je vous propose de revenir sur cette
indignation de nicolas sarkozy qui a
marqué un moment donné le débat de ce
jeudi soir il a été interrogé sur le
supposé financement libyen de sa
campagne présidentielle réponse
cinglante en question des du jade as
écouté
avez vous oui ou non reçu de l'argent
liquide de londres
financer votre campagne de 2007 comme
l'a affirmé l'intermédiaire ziad
takeddine alors pas seulement dans les
médias mais à la justice française hier
aussi quelle indignité
nous sommes sur le service public
vous en avez parlé on avait les revoir
vous n'avez pas honte de données est qu
un homme qui a fait de la prison qui a
été condamné à milan bra bhl reprises
pour diffamation et qui est un menteur
ce n'est pas l'idée voyez vous que je me
fais du service public
c'est une honte on voit le silence total
des candidats pendant cette réplique est
ce que pour vous les accusations ces
accusations avaient leur place dans ce
débat ce qu'il s'agissait plutôt d'un
jeu de rôle qu'est ce que vous non
sûrement pas cette question était
complètement déconnecté du débat vous
voyez qu'elle était préparée qu'elle
était programmée
c'est une attaque contre nicolas sarkozy
il n'y a pas eu des attaques comparables
contre les autres candidats contre aucun
c'est une attaque personnelle c'est une
attaque basse nicolas sarkozy y est
habitué et je dirais à peu près des
mêmes lieux des mêmes endroits se sont
déchaînés une violence contre nicolas
sarkozy qui manifestement des montres
qui m'a t j organise même endroit avec
ce qu'est ce que vous diriez qu'il ya un
problème votre nicolas sarkozy de
service public il y a eu une violence
inouïe des attaques de france 2 contre
nicolas sarkozy qui s'éclaire petit coin
de campagne contre nicolas sarkozy de la
part du service public en tout cas
on n'a jamais vu dans une campagne une
implication aussi forte pour
déstabiliser un candidat luc chatel à
votre place il ya quelques semaines nous
disait que c'était une honte de la part
de delphine ernotte la présidente du
service public vous dit quelque chose
aujourd'hui
il y a une stratégie manifestement qui
ne peut pas relever que du hasard ou que
des démarches individuelles
il y à des attaques convergentes des
émissions spéciales qui ont été faites
toutes dans la même direction des
portraits à charge des portraits à
charge des invités qui on a donné des
tribunes pour attaquer nicolas sarkozy
tout ça fait partie d'une stratégie et
cette question et resserre il hier soir
y contribuer alors il s'est passé des
choses avec ciotti cette semaine au
parlement s'il vient à l'assemblée qu'au
sénat l'examen du budget décidément
n'est pas un cours tranquille
s'il ya un coup de théâtre qui a eu lieu
à l'assemblée puisque le gouvernement a
été forcé à demander une seconde
délibération pourrait tenter de faire
adopter sa mesure phare c'est à dire
l'impôt à la source
la droite a en effet glissé dans le
débat un amendement généralisant le
prélèvement mensuel de l'impôt qui du
coup a fait tomber l'ensemble de
l'article instaurant le prélèvement à la
source
eric ciotti qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans les pays où vous avez compris ce
qui s'est passé c'est un coup politique
on peut le dire l'opposition a fait son
travail
nous considérons que cette mesure est
mauvaise et nous nous sommes opposés à
cette mesure
et comme la majorité ne doit pas penser
qu'elle est forcément très bonne elle ne
s'est pas mobilisée donc les choses sont
assez simples cette mesure est mauvaise
passe qu'elle va faire porter la
responsabilité du prélèvement de l'impôt
aux entreprises aux petites entreprises
parce qu'elle va donner des informations
personnelles que qui sont qui relève du
domaine privé à des acteurs qui n'ont
pas les connaître
donc il y à aussi derrière derrière ce
prélèvement à la source
l'idée caché masqué d'un rapprochement
d'une fusion entre l'impôt sur le revenu
et la csg
ça veut dire que il y aurait désormais
une progressivité de la csg qui
frapperait les classes moyennes c'est ça
l'idée d'associer entendu le fond de vos
arguments de vous et vos collègues mais
est ce que finalement sa place une telle
ou telle opposition idéologique dans un
hémicycle
en plein débat sur le budget votre
question est un peu inédite
ou est ce qu'elle aurait sa place cette
question c'est à l'assemblée c'est au
sénat très convoité la loi de finances
il ya une opposition elle vaut mieux
qu'elles s'expriment à la musique dans
la rue
donc c'est bien sûr on est très opposé à
cette mesure est manifestement la
majorité la soutiennent mollement
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas là hier pour
s'y opposer
ce qui veut dire qu'il y à quoi
dissensions au sein de cette majorité
qui ne serait pas favorable fait un
point sur son opus est pas inédit qui
dissensions dans la majorité y a pas
dissensions et un éclatement n'ya plus
de majorité des dislocations ça fait
très longtemps qu'il ya plus de morts
rites et c'est la lente agonie de ce
pouvoir qui s'achemine vers la fin d'un
règne qui aura été catastrophique non
pas pour les socialistes mais pour la
france
voilà il ça ça fait qu'aujourd'hui le
premier ministre qui en plus cette
majorité ne serait-ce que soit la fois
ça fait très longtemps qu'ils ne
tiendraient un coup de force alors ne
vous parle de manuel valls
il ya plus de majorité aujourd'hui très
clairement il ya plus de majorité voilà
source vote le daemon ça fait partie des
éléments on a vu la loi travail et la
mode l utilisation le recours aux 49 3
on voit aujourd hui avec d'autorité
l'absence de l'absence de majorité donc
fin c'est peut-être un acte d'autorité
c'est un acte surtout de contraintes
contre la majorité gouvernementale parce
qu'il n'ya plus de majorité
alors justement au sénat le débat
budgétaire va tourner court depuis ce
que la majorité sénatoriale a décidé de
déposer une question préalable ça veut
dire qu'on ne discutera à peine de ce
texte et puis ça a renvoyé directement
l'assemblée nationale explications
jordan qu'à un budget bidon
électoralistes ou maquillée comme une
voiture volée voilà comment la majorité
sénatoriale qualifie le projet de loi de
finances pour 2010 est elle conclut
rejeter sans même le faire voter grâce à
l'adoption d'une question préalable
les sénateurs n'ont pas à apporter leur
garantie leur caution les sénateurs
n'ont pas à apporter leurs votes à des
mesures électorales qui sont d'ailleurs
des mesures sans lendemain puisque ce
budget ne sera pas exécutée tout le
monde le sait donc pas théâtre d'ombrés
pas de jeu de rôle la sincérité la
sincérité des convictions et des
réalités
et pour justifier leur rejet les
sénateurs de droite et du centre met en
avant plusieurs points
l'envolée de la masse salariale de
l'état qui augmenterait de 4 % une
surestimation des dépenses 7,4 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires en 2017
d'après les élus et surtout une
sous-estimation du déficit le
gouvernement table sur 2 7%
la commission des finances du sénat est
bien plus pessimiste et l'estiment à 3,2
pour cent ce budget c'est plutôt la
hotte de noël à du parti socialiste et
du candidat hollande du comté à valls on
verra bien à l'arrivée qui est candidat
mais ça n'est pas un exercice qui permet
au parlement de se prononcer sur des
vraies scheer et que aujourd'hui la
france est à la traîne niveau européen
elle est à la traîne en termes de
croissance est à la traîne en terme de
déficit et donc la copie du gouvernement
et finalement il est déjà caduc
al'inverse la commission européenne est
plus optimiste
elle voit la france passait en dessous
de la ligne rouge des 3% de déficit
public imposée par bruxelles
un contre argument pour le gouvernement
le mot sénat vous voulez pas assumer
votre programme pour l'avenir le sénat
l'alternance qui le laboratoire de
l'alternance même je proclame pas le
sénat a eu raison de de clore ce débat
très vite les arguments soulevés par
bruno retailleau sont naturellement
légitimer et pertinents c'est une
supercherie ce budget c'est au mollet
xavier proposer des choses c'est un
budget de faux semblants c'est un budget
de maquillage c'est un décor potemkine
qui masque les décombres de la faillite
socialiste les prévisions de croissance
les jeunes de son âge on était peut être
revu à la baisse mais elle reste très
éloignée de la réalité de la probabilité
de la croissance donc les déficits sont
sous-évaluées on sait très bien qu'on ne
saura pas 2,7 pour cent
il y à une ardoise qui va être laissé
justement des chèques en blanc qui ont
été tirés sur l'avenir près de 10
milliards d'euros de dépenses qui vont
être portés à la charge de la future
majorité justement c'est la réalité donc
nous disons très clairement que nous ne
cautionnons pas ce débat il y aura une
loi de finances rectificative
dès l'élection de nicolas sarkozy prix
de la nouvelle autorité vous apprenez
quelque chose alors ils risquent nicolas
sarkozy le seul à porter cette loi de
finances rectificative
dès juillet 2017 avec une diminution de
la fiscalité de 40 milliards d'euros
-10% l'impôt sur le revenu pour les
ménages c'est important et en même temps
la programmation la vote d'une loi de
programmation quinquennale qui prévoira
la baisse de 100 milliards d'euros des
dépenses publiques surtout le justement
vous évoquez lardoise que président
de droite s'il devait être élu erythrée
et donc ça veut dire que vous devrez en
échange prendre des mesures quand même
d'austérité assez forte pour réaliser
votre programme vu que les marges de
manoeuvre sont quand même assez étroit
il n'y aura pas des mesures d'austérité
il y aura des mesures de réformes
structurelles la croissance des jeux
d'apparence qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
les mettre en oeuvre
aviez-vous jugé que le budget insincère
visiblement il y aura des ardoises dans
l'est pas car comme vous dites on verra
ce qui sera supprimée ou pas dans les
mesures qui ont été annoncées
beaucoup de je pense par exemple à ces
mesures
bidon de formation de financement de
stage
cette vidéo le coût est de 2 milliards
d'euros simplement pour faire en sorte
que monsieur hollande revendiquent ils
inverser la courbe du chômage croyait
pas aux états mais c'est bidon parce que
ce sont de faux stage ce son qui
débouche sur aucun emploi réel c'est pas
comme ça qu'on réglera à coups de
dépenses publiques
la problématique des impôts ensuite il
ya l'augmentation du point d'indicé de
la fonction publique celui-là y sera il
sera acquis 0 6%
je vous donne rendez-vous seront +0 6%
en février donc c'est un coût 1 4
milliard d'euros de plus à la charge du
budget de l'état et des collectivités
locales
il y aura des réformes structurelles
vous parler des mesures qui seront des
décisions seront pas ceux 16 l'âge de
départ en retraite qui sera emporté
c'est dans le programme de nicolas
sarkozy à 63 ans en 2020
le gain à terme ces 20 milliards d'euros
de dépenses publiques en moins donc ce
sont des efforts extrêmement importants
la diminution du nombre des emplois
publics et pas forcément des réformes
très populaire ce seront des réformes
difficiles mais là aussi c'est pour ça
qu'il faut choisir le bon candidat à la
primaire celui qui n'a jamais reculé
devant la rue nicolas sarkozy pendant
cinq ans l'opposition à la réforme des
retraites
l'opposition à la réforme des
universités je le redis parce que
j'avais un gouvernement n'avait osé
s'attaquer avec cette force à des sujets
aussi sensibles il ya eu la mobilisation
des syndicats il y a eu la mobilisation
des syndicats étudiants
il n'a pas reculé il n'a pas parlé de la
sécurité oui le troisième thème de cette
émission michael l'histoire d'un fichier
qui fait un peu peur nom de code tu es
comme titres électroniques sécurisées il
s'agit d'un méga fichiers instauré par
décret récemment
il regroupe les données biométriques de
pratiquement tous les français c'est à
dire les détenteurs de titres d'identité
les sénateurs demandent sa suppression
deuxième passage en deux jours pour
bernard cazeneuve devant les sénateurs
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
s'explique dans l'hémicycle sur le
fichier tess un débat qui était réclamée
par les parlementaires après la
publication du décret en catimini par le
gouvernement s'il ya des modifications
apportées nous les importerons la
représentation nationale sera informé de
ces éléments elle pourra poursuivre le
débat avec nous et je modifierai si
c'était nécessaire le dispositif en
fonction des recommandations qui nous
sont adressées pour certains sénateurs
le gouvernement n'a pas suffisamment
approfondi la question
il existe actuellement des fichiers non
informatiques qui centralise les données
des français car les menaces de piratage
inquiète je pense que le fichier de tous
les français m tous les fichiers sur
tous les français sur un fichier
informatique
c'est une menace pour les libertés
menace d'identification menaces de
piratage
le fish et par conséquent je pense qu'il
faut étudier les autres solutions que
propose la cnil ou que propose le
conseil national du numérique dans
l'hémicycle le président de la
commission des lois philippe pas à
demander au gouvernement de suspendre la
création du fichier
elle se dit quelle est votre opinion sur
ce dossier qui suscite beaucoup de
polémiques est ce que bernard cazeneuve
doit à conserver le décret tel qu'il est
qui instaure donc ce méga fichiers mois
par principe je suis favorable à ce
fichier d'abord je veux noter que cette
initiative qui relève de la précédente
majorité lorsque
claude guéant était ministre de
l'intérieur pourquoi parce que on a
aujourd'hui des dizaines de milliers de
français qui sont victimes d'usurpation
d'identité parce que nous avons plus que
jamais la nécessité de sécuriser les
titres d'identité le but est de passer à
une démarche biométrique comme c'est
déjà le cas je soulève je le souligne
pardon pour les passeports
donc je ne j'ai l'impression que
certains jouent à se faire peur il n'y a
aucun risque aucune crainte à avoir
le risque qu'il peut y avoir c'est un
effet que ce fichier soit piraté je ne
vois pas de risques pour les libertés
publiques
qu'est ce qui serait dangereux de
données qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce
fichier il y a le nom le prénom et il y
à l empreinte digitale dollars 20 euros
il ya donc des données des données qui
existe qui je crois ne sont pas
attentatoire ou ne font pas partie 2-2
le de la vivre porte atteinte à la vie
privée elles seront tout de même
centrale veut il peut y avoir dans une
seule vague guibal l'a souligné il peut
y avoir un risque de piratage de cela
nous donnons nous lisent outils pour
sécuriser bien entendu comme c'est le
cas pour les passeports ya jamais eu de
problème pour les passeports jan figel
les passeports relève les mêmes éléments
d'identité très exactement que ce qui
pourrait l'être avec ce fichier tu es
donc sur le principe
ce fichier est utile c'est pas parce que
le gouvernement ne propose que je vais
dire le contraire moi je suis cohérent
je pense que nous sommes face à une
menace maximale à une menace terroriste
qu'il faut arrêter d'avoir cette
approche un peu bisounours
voilà ce qui nous menace ce n'est pas le
gouvernement
ce n'est pas l'atteinte aux libertés
individuelles ce sont les terroristes
donc soyons plus que suffisant
aujourd'hui non c'est une super
naturellement pas suffisant voix s'il
n'y a rien de particulier dans ce
fichier
les gens entendent des cris d'orfraie
qui souhait même heureux comme à droite
rui buffet bien sûr toujours eu ce débat
on l'a eue sur tous les textes on l'a
eue sur la loire enseigne membres j'ai
fauté la loi renseignements gelé
activement soutenu dans la main dans la
la majorité il ya eu des oppositions il
y en a eu très minoritaire chez nous
mais il ya quelques voiles sont pas
majoritaires je pense que ce fichier
participe d'une meilleure sécurité pour
autant qu'on y apporte les garanties
techniques qui protège de tout risque de
du jeu de pénétration dans ce fichier
eric ciotti c'est l'heure d'accueillir
notre partenaire du fica routine
jarrassé bonjour d'ibm pour mickaël
bonjean katia bonjour bonjour eric
ciotti vous l'avez dit vous pensez que
nicolas sarkozy sera en tête à l'issue
du premier tour dimanche on a vu sur
twitter françois baroin annoncé un
meeting de nicolas sarkozy lundi soir
dans sa ville de troyes
quand même est-ce que c'est pas un peu
présomptueux de vendre un peu la peau de
l'ours
non on est là pour gagner on voit sur le
terrain qui a de la force ce qui est
quand on est engagé pour des idées quand
on est engagé aussi pour pour un homme
par conception de de ce que peut être la
direction la gestion de de la nation et
bien sonné mobilisés donc oui on sera
tous lundi soir à troyes avec nicolas
sarkozy françois baroin c'est une
certitude
absolument parlons un peu là déjà tué
mon billet par le roi la candidature
d'emmanuel macron c'était une actualité
importante cette semaine on sent bien
qu'ils convoitent un peu le l'électorat
centriste qui qui est aussi peut-être
celui d'alain juppé est-ce que c'est
finalement ça peut être une bonne
nouvelle une bonne chose pour un nicolas
sarkozy je fais pas ses calculs à
plusieurs bandes
je crois que la candidature de macron
c'est d'abord le problème de la gauche
là c'est une étape de plus dans la
désintégration en plein vol de cette
majorité on en parlait tout à l'heure de
ce gouvernement
macron c'est un bébé hollande il se
retourne contre son créateur avec une
violence très très forte
si je dirais que c'est leur problème le
premier ministre depuis l'allemagne
manifestement pose sa candidature contre
le président de la république qui
hésitent à être candidat à la primaire
des socialistes
tout ça c'est un pataquès général nous
ça nous concerne pas nous on est six
apparitions en effet un candidat
antisystème ni droite ni gauche ça vous
concerne
il est parti système il est
l'incarnation du système qu'ils
dénoncent
il a été secrétaire général de l'elysée
il est banquier d'affaires
il a été vicaire france d'aujourd'hui
n'a été ni droite ni gauche si vous
aussi vous savez ce qu'il propose je
serais heureux que vous me l'apprenez il
ya des choses il ya de la communication
est ce qu'ils proposent sur les
questions de sécurité un peu de miel qui
produisent sur le communautarisme je l'
ai entendu parler d'une responsabilité
de la france au moment des attentats
terroristes
quelque chose qui m'inquiète au plus
profond cette approche un peu
ultralibérale qui serait la
revendication d'une forme qu'il incarne
une forme de centrisme façon le centre
est-ce-qu'il pro à la jupe et c'était la
question du genre à six comparants votre
pause
je crois qu'il prend essentiellement à
sa famille politique pour l'instant tout
cas moi je ne me reconnais pas dans
cette approche est le vainqueur de la
primaire ne se reconnaîtra pas dans
cette approche
alors il sera nicolas pas une bonne
nouvelle pour nicolas sarkozy alors non
je crois qu'on encore une fois c'est la
sphère de
de la gorge des panneaux team parlant de
françois hollande maintenant vous avez
lancé une procédure judiciaire pour
violation du secret défense vos
collègues députés ont également lancé
une procédure de destitution à
l'assemblée qui va être examinée par le
bureau de l'assemblée la semaine
prochaine vous y croyez vraiment à cette
procédure ou est ce que c'est un acte
symbolique la procédure de destitution
c'est un acte politique qui fait le
constat que le président de la
république a trahi les devoirs de sa
charge en livrant à la presse et donc à
nos ennemis des secrets classé
confidentiel défense ou secret défense
qui sont de nature à menacer à mettre en
péril nos armées qui sont engagés en
syrie et en irak
c'était démarche qui sera analysé par le
bureau étudié par le bureau de
l'assemblée
ensuite je l'espère par la commission
des lois et dans l'hémicycle moi j'ai
déposé plainte
non pas contre françois hollande puisque
il a une forme d'irresponsabilité pénale
en tant que chef d'état j'ai saisi le
procureur de la république de paris pour
violation du confidentiel défense
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il y avait eu
espérait disent que c'est évoqué dans le
livre de monsieur d'avé l'homme et c'est
évoquer plus qu'évoqué puisque les
documents sont produits en photo dans un
article du monde qui est paru sous la
signature de monsieur d'un velum en août
dernier c'est un scandale absolu donc
maintenant à la justice de se saisir la
justice est très rapide sur certains
dossiers et elle est très motivée sur
certaines notions vous recherchez convoi
zeiss d'un prêteur de magistrats qui
s'intéresse à certaines personnalités
j'aimerais qu'il y avait la même
mobilisation pour des pour chercher qui
a fait à procéder à cette violation de
secret défense
il y a eu violation du secret défense je
m'étonne que d'initiatives
d'abord le ministre de la défense n'est
pas porté plainte
je lui ai demandé par deux fois il n'a
même pas répondu à mon courrier
si j'ai saisi personnellement au titre
de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale le parquet de paris c'est parce
que le ministre de la défense n'a pas
voulu le faire donc c'est à la justice
aujourd'hui de faire son travail et je
méthodes qu'il n'y ait pas d'information
judiciaire ou d' enquête préliminaire
qui soit ouverte sur n'importe quel
autre dossier d'autant qu'il aurait
touché quelqu'un qui aurait pu concerner
l'opposition cela aurait été dans la
mitaine par exemple par exemple je pense
que healy a très clairement un zèle qui
est beaucoup moins expressif sur ce
dossier le porte-parole du gouvernement
steffen loeffel a réagi de façon assez
étonnante un veau procédure il a dit
lorsque on s'est débrouillés comme eric
ciotti pour ne pas faire son service
militaire
lorsqu'on est un tire-au-flanc on ne
fait pas de procès sur le secret défense
vous avez une réponse à lui faire c'est
une opération de dilution ou de
diversion qu'est-ce que ça à voir ma
situation personnelle et il ya une
trentaine d'années maintenant est
menacée et des soldats qui sont tous les
jours en syrie en irak
monsieur le foll est un petit ministre
médiocre c'est un petit porteur d'eau de
monsieur hollande
ça a été le pire ministre de
l'agriculture de la vème république il a
mis les agriculteurs dans la précarité
par son incompétence c'est le dernier
soutienne monsieur hollande il fait son
job il le fait médiocrement mais ça
m'importe peu
dernière question pour finir marine le
pen qui a des volets son logo cette
semaine c'est une rose bleu dépourvue
d'épinés je sais pas si ça vous inspire
quelque chose à la roseraie du bleu la
rose c'est généralement c'était le jeu
du parti socialiste donc ça veut dire
que l'inspiration est à gauche on savait
que national avait déjà le programme de
monsieur mélenchon la référence prise et
au ps honte à ces taux élevés droite
c'est assez étonnant c'est un peu gagne
en 2017 comme la comme l'a dit manuel
valls cette semaine elle pourrait gagner
si la droite n'était pas la droite
si les républicains ne portait pas un
projet d'alternance force pour ça que
nous avons besoin et c'est pour ça que
je soutiens le groupe risque que les
colas pepsi cola sarkozy parce que
nicolas sarkozy est le garant de cette
alternance et s'ils font pas nicolas
sarkozy lui ait fait selon juppé par
exemple je peux gagner je pense qu'elle
sera plus haute en tout cas je ne dis
pas qu'elle peut gagner mais je pense
qu'elle sera plus haut d'ailleurs une
enquête qui paraît ce matin le démontre
au premier tour
elle est plus haute si c'est alain juppé
la droite doit être elle même aborder
tous les sujets ce qui préoccupe les
français le communautarisme le
terrorisme l'immigration sans tabou et
avec versus merci à tous d'avoir été
notre avis laissés afin cette émission
on se retrouve mon front prochain bonne
semaine à tous